sí
hemos repasado la primera de las tres
cosas que necesitamos para crear un
simulador de partículas tenemos fórmulas
que describen cómo se moverán las
partículas de acuerdo a las leyes de la
física aquí desarrollaremos fórmulas que
describen cómo se comportan las
partículas durante las colisiones si la
velocidad es perpendicular al suelo al
momento de la colisión y la colisión es
perfecta entonces la velocidad se
invierte en el mundo real la dirección
se invierte y la magnitud se reduce
ligeramente a una fracción como vimos en
la primera lección podemos ejemplificar
las pérdidas fraccionarias multiplicando
el factor que mide la elasticidad de la
colisión de esta manera si ves la
velocidad de caída antes de la colisión
con el piso entonces la velocidad
llamémosla depriman después de la
colisión está dada por d prima que es
igual a negativa multiplicada por ver
aquí que representa la elasticidad un
número entre cero y uno
y el signo negativo indica que la
dirección se invierte después de la
colisión y no hay pérdida de energía si
es menor que 1 entonces se perderá un
poco de energía
pero qué pasa si la velocidad forma un
ángulo con el suelo veamos lo que pasa
observa que la pelota rebota igual que
un rayo de luz que se refleja en un
espejo es decir si la velocidad de
entrada forma un ángulo theta con el
suelo
entonces la velocidad de salida llamada
be prima forma el mismo ángulo
para calcular de prima a partir de b
tomemos b como la suma de dos vectores
la velocidad paralela al suelo de
paralelas y la velocidad perpendicular
al suelo de perpendicular la única
fuerza durante el choque es
perpendicular al suelo porque el suelo
empuja la pelota hacia arriba así pues
la componente paralela no cambia y la
componente perpendicular como
anteriormente vimos se va a invertir lo
cual significa que mi prima es igual a b
paralela menos de perpendicular si a
esto le añadimos la elasticidad
observemos esta ecuación
muy bien podemos usar este concepto
tomando la velocidad como la suma de las
componentes paralelas y perpendicular
para analizar un ejemplo en que dos
partículas y j con la misma masa
colisiona dibujemos lo para que quede
más claro la recta y jota que va del
centro de la partícula y al centro de la
partícula gota desempeña la función de
la componente perpendicular al suelo
así que escribimos sabéis como la suma
de dos vectores tal como se muestra aquí
podemos hacer lo mismo con bj
la única fuerza que actúa sobre las
partículas durante la colisión se
encuentra a lo largo de la recta y j
como en el ejemplo anterior puesto que
ninguna fuerza actúa en dirección
paralela las velocidades de las
direcciones paralelas no cambian para
determinar exactamente lo que sucede en
dirección perpendicular necesitamos
entrar en temas más avanzados
específicamente conservación de la
energía y cantidad de impulso
si aplicamos estos conceptos y suponemos
que las partículas tienen la misma masa
tendremos que la partícula y obtiene la
velocidad perpendicular de jota y
viceversa es decir ambas partículas
intercambian sus velocidades
perpendiculares
esto significa que después de la
colisión las velocidades de prima
y de prima j son determinadas por estas
ecuaciones
eso es todo respecto a las colisiones de
las partículas en el siguiente ejercicio
podrás repasar estas ecuaciones las
cuales las describen